Why is bone broth not good for me, the cancer that I have?
So bone broth is, let's define what bone broth is.
So bone broth was first, really came into use about 10, 12 years ago with some certain
diets to help heal the gut.
So bone broth here is, how you make bone broth, if you're going to make your own bone broth,
is that you take some beef bones or some chicken bones and you cook it in water, unload
for a couple days.
Some people did this in their crock pot, unload, or even on high in the crock pot, so it's
like at a slow boil and you're basically trying to get all the nutrients out of the bone
itself.
Why?
Well, the reason is that bone broth contains a very high quantity of glutamate.
So bone broth takes, carries a high quantity of glutamate.
So remember what glutamate is.
So glutamate is an amino acid, so glutamate is an amino acid.
So amino acids make up proteins.
So shade of amino acids equals a protein.
Well glutamate is a specific amino acid that comes from protein.
It's very high in animal proteins and it is high in bones.
So if you boil bones and you make your own bone broth, you'll have a lot of glutamate.
Why is that good?
Why was that a big craze to use bone broth?
Well, especially when you're doing gut healing protocols, you have gut issues.
Glutamate, remember, we talked about this a lot.
So sorry for those that know this already.
Glutamate helps stimulate growth.
And if you're trying to heal your gut, your gut cells, your epithelial lighting of your
gut really feeds off of glutamate and we're trying to heal our gut, we're trying to grow
new gut cells and an excess amount of glutamate in our gut will help increase the rate of
replication of the epithelial cells.
Well, that sounds like a great thing if you want to heal your gut.
But that is never a good thing if you have cancer.
So if you have cancer, you do not want to feed your body excess amounts of glutamate.
Where I said glutamate is an amino acid, it will be there is going to be some glutamate
in all proteins, even plant-based proteins will have glutamate.
But animal-based proteins, meat and bones will have a much higher concentration of glutamate.
So that's why people that especially people that their cancers are feeding more off of glutamate
or people that have cancers that are epithelial-based, that it's not a good idea to be using any excess
glutamate.
Where would you get excess glutamate?
In using bone broth, in using protocols that were gut healing protocols, in using different
supplements that have glutamated it.
Why would a supplement have glutamated it?
Because it's typically a gut healing supplement.
So a lot of the gut healing powders that you would use to help heal your gut have glutamated
it.
Our clear GI has glutamate, but I actually picked clear GI and used that one as our product
for gut healing because it has a fairly low amount of glutamate compared to some other gut
healing protocols.
Some gut healing protocols have four to five grams of glutamate per serving, super high amount
of glutamate.
Now that'd be just fine if you don't have cancer or you absolutely positively know you don't
have cancer.
And you have major gut product problems you want to heal your gut.
There's nothing wrong with doing that on a short-term basis.
I still would do it on a long-term basis because you don't know if you have cancer cells growing
in your body.
You certainly don't want to feed them and have that be an issue.
So the other negative glutamate is glutamate, especially for those who have a certain G-U-T-G-D-Fx,
these G-L-U-T-G-D-Fx, I think it is.
You convert glutamate, the amino acid to glutamate glutamate is a neurotransmitter function
that is a neurotransmitter of your body, and if you convert glutamate to glutamate more
quickly because you have that specific G-D-Fx, then that can be a problem.
So we talked about this just a couple of weeks ago, I think I remember correctly.
And that could be a major issue with people that have ADD, ADHD, anxiety, OCD issues.
So you need glutamates in your body, glutamates as a function, as an excitatory neurotransmitter
in your brain.
They help wake you up in the morning, they help get you going, people that are exceptionally
intelligent have been shown to have kind of excess glutamates.
They tend to be more OCD type people, but they tend to also be very driven.
So there's nothing wrong with glutamate.
Too much glutamate could make you more wired, can make you not be able to fall asleep, can
make you full of anxiety, can make you unhealthy OCD, and even disorganized.
And then you don't become a person that is, you know, accomplishes a lot of life.
So if that you kind of fall into that category emotionally and anxiety is, you know, would
be something that you would categorize yourself in, I would say it might serve you, even if
you didn't know anything about your genetics at that point, to decrease your animal proteins
and see if that would help because you may have an excess amount of glutamate.
So for cancer, glutamine can feed cancers, glutamine increases the rate of cell growth, glutamine
increases growth potential in cancer, glutamine also converts to glutamates, which is not good
for brain cancer, also, as you mentioned, and certainly not good for other emotional issues.
So I'm not against animal proteins, but we tend to eat way too much animal proteins in our
society, and we might be better served by looking at more plant-based sources as well.